Short and sweet number 11.
The Shulchan Aruch, as understood by the Gra, says that it is forbidden to drink any alcoholic or prestigious non-alcoholic beverages in a non-Jewish establishment.
Now this Gezerah we discussed was a later Gezerah than the Isser of B'shalakum and Pasakum,
and therefore it is not subject to the same level of restrictions as those previous Gezerahs.
One exception would be that if the drink was removed from the non-Jews domain,
Again, assuming it's a kosher beverage, then it would be allowed.
Now, how far does it have to be removed?
The Gra, Paschan, that the beverage must be brought into the Jew's domain, the Rishus, whether that's their home or a hotel room, it has to be that far removed.
However, the Darken Tshuva says that it only needs to be taken out of the non-Jew's domain.
It doesn't have to be brought all the way to the Rishus of the Jew.
We did say that everyone agrees that if it's a designated outdoor eating area of a non-Jewish bar, that's still considered inside of the non-Jew's domain.
The Shach told us that this prohibition does have an exception.
In a case where it would cause animosity not to drink in this establishment, then it would be permissible to drink.
As well as we mentioned, another exception is if it's a sporadic and inconsistent manner of drinking, it would be permitted.
So the example we said was if a person does not sit down, they're just walking around with a drink, and this is not frequent,
this is a one-time or very infrequent occurrence, then it would be permissible.
The Huchas Katanos, the Kaf HaChaim, actually said that the Shulchan Aruch holds that non-alcoholic beverages are permitted.
He only forbids alcoholic drinks, but the Groth said that the Shulchan Aruch held even non-alcoholic drinks are problematic if they are prestigious.
We have the opinion of the Ramah, who held that only date beer is prohibited in a non-Jewish establishment.
Date beer was what was drunk in the times of the Gemara, and that was the only thing that was prohibited.
All other beverages, according to the Rama, would be permitted in a non-Jewish establishment or a non-Jewish bar.
The question of conducting a business meeting over a beer at a non-Jewish bar, we said, is a machukes or Moshe Feinstein held.
It would be allowed because we'd have to avoid causing any animosity with the non-Jewish employee or boss or co-worker.
In a situation where there's no animosity, it would not be allowed.
But to avoid it, avoid animosity, we will allow it.
The Orletzion, however, said it would be forbidden.
However, he did say that if it was non-alcoholic drinks that were being drunk at the bar, it would be permissible.
We then even discussed the question of drinking coffee, which is a prestigious drink, albeit not alcoholic, but it is a prestigious drink.
Can a person drink a coffee at a non-Jewish-owned coffee shop?
So the Shulchan Aruch, as understood by the Gra, would say that it's forbidden.
We said that the Halachas Kitanos and the Kaf HaChaim would say it's permitted because the drink is non-alcoholic.
The Rama, we said, would be subject to a Machlokas, the Pischei Teshuva, Chochmas Adam, even the Vada Arbarotzo is a very early source,
say that in the Rama, even according to the Rama, it would be forbidden to drink the coffee.
However, Rehershal Schachter did tell us that even though one should follow this Chochmas Adam,
if it's not common to socialize with strangers at a coffee shop, there's room to be lenient.
Okay, then we discussed the question of attending a non-Jewish party.
So, again, this party is being arranged by non-Jews.
So, in a situation where it's being arranged by non-Jews and the majority of attendees are non-Jewish,
Rav Moshe Feinstein said it would be forbidden to be at that party.
However, the one exception Rav Moshe said is if there would be animosity,
it would be permitted to attend and even to drink an alcoholic drink.
The Orletzion held that it would be permitted to attend this party, but not to drink alcohol, even in a situation of animosity.
So that would be the Machlokas subject between the Rav Moshe and the Orletzion.
We did mention, though, if the party is being organized by non-Jews, but the majority of attendees are Jewish,
so then we said everyone would agree that it would be permitted to attend and even to drink alcohol.
The question of attending a non-Jewish wedding feast was Machlokas, the Taz said,
It's an Issa Dar Esa, and you're not allowed to attend, even if it's going to cause animosity, you cannot go.
The Shach, however, said it's only an Issa Midr HaBanan, and therefore, if it will cause animosity to not attend, it would be permitted.
The Sefer B'ni Yisroel Amin said that if the Jews have their own table, it would be permissible as well.
And we said if a Ger wanted to attend their parents' birthday party, or even a regular meal of their parents, it would be permissible,
even though there are non-Jews present, because they are Ger.
But we said it would be permissible for a couple of factors, including the fact that mitzvah keep it of an aim, and that would be permissible as well.